now how could i not talk about exactly
how our incredible interview finally
ended after all it's made global
headlines because apparently the promo
was rigged donald trump himself issued
two statements branding it fake news
well here's what really happened it is
true that i had a lot longer with him
than i've been promised maybe three
times as long in fact but whenever i've
interviewed trump in the past you buy as
much time as you can and he stays as
long as he wants that's how the system
works the real problem it seemed to me
was that he was already simmering with
anger about the confrontation over the
alleged election i didn't agree with him
but also that he's his aide was
incredibly irritating and incompetent as
he tried to stop the interview
what do you think if we were an hour in
yeah sorry i'm just wrapping up
the last question yeah yeah yeah one
last question
that's it no yeah yeah last question
four times
he just didn't know how to do it so i
just carried on uh there's been so much
frenzy speculation and hyperbole about
all that but the truth is trump clearly
left very irritated uh partly i think
about our confrontation partly about the
fact being said this secret dossier
stuff i'd written about him before but i
think mainly because of his incredibly
incompetent director of communications
or should i say current director of
communications this is the same taylor
who tweeted this about me
hmm pathetic failure not so sure you
should be issuing those kind of
statements taylor given your own
pathetic and failed attempt to stop this
interview from ending all i know is
because of your ineptitude your boss
president trump wasn't very happy and i
would say that's more of a problem for
your employment status than it is for me
and my show but in the interest of full
transparency because to be honest with
you it's quite fun to watch what goes on
behind the scenes we'd normally cut this
out but i'm going to show it all in real
time because right in the middle of all
this uh we start talking about donald
trump's hole-in-one at golf uh which is
a bit nuts but that's the way these
things sometimes go down it started with
a little tangle about covid it moves
into golf and in the middle of it all
hell breaks loose take a look
are you glad that the vaccine program
worked i know that you i was surprised
i'll be honest but i was pleasantly
surprised that you came out and said
that you'd not only been fully
vaccinated but you thought other people
should well we saved tens of millions of
lives maybe this would have been the
spanish flu of 1917 had we not come up
and i got it done in nine months as
opposed to they were projecting from
five to 12 years i got it done in nine
months i'm very proud of it you were
great i'm against mandates right
strongly against mandates but i'm very
proud of what we did i saved
worldwide tens of millions of lives one
last question do you accept that early
on in the pandemic
that you didn't take it seriously enough
or you were being told how serious it
was no i don't accept i was sharing that
with the american people i'm a
cheerleader for this country
i want to be positive for this country i
take everything seriously and i took
that very seriously but i'm a
cheerleader for the country and our
country came out of it better than
anybody else we've done a great job my
final question president trump it's been
good to catch up with you after this uh
lengthy time i haven't mentioned it
that's it no yeah yeah last question
four times no i i realize that you're
lying
i'm not like very different i just
haven't asked you you're a very dissent
this was this was a 20-minute interview
listen this was a 20-minute interview
uh i think it's fine it's fine it's i
haven't asked them fantastic in your
opinion i wanted to end with the holy
one i just haven't asked about the holy
one do you want to go ahead
you recently got a hole in one playing
golf with ernie else one of the great
golfers of the world what was that like
for you well it was great he's a great
guy great player one of the most
beautiful swings they say in the history
of golf and very powerful and i made it
with him and actually three other tour
pros
and it was quite a thrill talk me
through the shot
well i hit the ball it was hit well it
felt good the wind was blowing hard into
my face it was a five iron that went 181
yards and it went clank right into the
hole it landed on the green in one
bounce and it went clank and ernie who's
a low-key guy
one of the reasons he's acceptable the
big easy right
but ernie and the other pros started
jumping up and down in the air and i
said why are you guys so excited he says
because we don't see hollow ones
they make i guess one every three
tournaments and then you have to be in
the group so it's really wonderful i've
had seven this was a seven seven hundred
seven this was my seventh which isn't
that high in number believe it or not if
somebody plays golf
i hear the record is 49. okay people
should buy a round of drinks in the bar
afterwards i don't know but i would
certainly have been happy to you don't
drink
i don't drink now at least traditionally
you buy around that is true that is true
did you do that probably happened i
didn't check but probably happened
because i owned the club i'm sure it
happened congratulations on the holy one
all right thank you very much thank you
very much thank you very much we
appreciate it
okay thank you okay let's go that was a
great interview yeah that's fine thank
you very much i really appreciate it
turn the camera off
so there you have it info call it
whatever you like mr president
i wouldn't have called our promo a
rigged promo you did leave pretty angry
it certainly wasn't a happy ending
and frankly i'm a bit disappointed about
that because i did think it was a
brilliant interview we agreed on a
number of issues we disagreed vehemently
about others but you were extremely
entertaining
very direct in some of the things he was
saying it's made headlines around the
world and i just hope that now you've
seen the whole thing in totality we can
put our little spat behind us you can
park your two statements perhaps to a
little corner of your office and maybe
even see it in your heart to pick up the
phone
and we can have a virtual cup of tea you
in palm beach me and london
milk no sugar and yorkshire gold always
the best tea
you